here's the latest after being near  someone who had the coronavirus Texas  senator Ted Cruz said he will now work  from home yeah yeah when asked for  comment Ted's wife and two children said  what a dick  president Trump President Trump is  continuing to downplay the risks of the  coronavirus yes yet today he said relax  you're far more likely to die from the  cuts I made to Obamacare so those who  get so long before any virus due to fear  this is a big story due to the fears of  the corona virus  Ireland has canceled its st. Patrick's  Day parade they canceled it yeah yeah  the Irish are being urged to stay home  get drunk and punch themselves so this  crowd reaction on when they said Ireland  cancelled their say yoga what do you  care what Boston did to adjust you read  Boston dancing yeah yeah yeah we don't  need no parade to drink my day yeah we  can do that fine on our own